president trump in recent weeks has been
on a crusade against
critical race theory i believe this is
possibly the most important thing he's
done with his presidency
even if he hadn't taken any active steps
against it to simply shine light on it
to make people
aware of it and two as the leftist would
say
proble problematize it i guess is the
phrase that is an enormous public
service
but trump has gone further than that
he's um and here's the latest he tweeted
this last night he said
a few weeks ago i banned efforts to
indoctrinate government employees with
divisive and harmful sex and race-based
ideologies
today i've expanded that ban to people
and companies that do business with our
country the united states military
government
contractors and grantees americans
should be taught to take pride in our
great country and if you don't
there's nothing in it for you um so
that's a very good thing critical race
theory is a scourge it is an ideological
cancer it has
infected our societal bloodstream and
the effects have been
devastating the racial strife in our
country today riots much of the violence
this can all be traced at least in part
back to critical race theory
now i think before we go to any any
beyond that though i think we probably
first have to answer a basic question
which is
what is critical race theory and for
that so that you know i'm not
giving you a biased or cherry-picked
definition
i will go to a liberal source i'll go to
the boston globe article it was just
written which is meant to be a defense
of critical race theory
um hence first henceforth referred to as
crt by the way
just for short and also
dismantlingracism.org
which is an online resource that's
supposed to help you well
dismantle racism though as we'll see
probably constructing racism or
spreading racism would be a better name
for that website
first here's the boston globe article it
says scholars say the president's
remarks about crt
prove he fundamentally misunderstands
critical race theory and its aims
i am a thousand percent sure that trump
does not know what critical race theory
is i have never been more sure of
anything in my life
said kiara bridges professor at the
university of california berkeley law
school
and author of the textbook critical race
theory a primer
she goes on and he certainly doesn't
understand the debates within and about
critical race theory
scholarship by critical race theory
emerged in the 1970s and 80s in response
to what legal scholars perceived to be
the failures of
traditional efforts approaches to
thinking about race and civil rights
which tended to conceptualize racism
very narrowly according to bridges
as a problem of individual bad actors
the movement's architects including the
late derrick bell the first tenured
black professor at harvard law school
and kimberley crenshaw a professor at
the ucla school
of law in columbia law school who first
coined the term critical race theory
um says racism is not extraordinary
she continued race and racism are
basically baked into everything we do in
our society
it's embedded in our institutions it's
embedded in our minds and our hearts
then it goes on despite the progress and
promises of the civil rights movement
critical race theorists argue that
racism infects all of our societal
institutions
from public education to the criminal
justice system what appears to be
progress in the law
is actually concealing a new modality of
structural societal ra
systemic racism that according to rajesh
sampath
an associate professor of philosophy of
justice rights and social change
at brandeis university namely our laws
and
constitutions don't protect everyone
equally he said
okay so that's the boston globe
racism is embedded in everything we do
america is racist down to its very core
american well white americans are racist
in their hearts in their minds
everything is racist racism is
everywhere and
even even when it looks like racism is
being addressed
by laws and policies really those laws
like constitutional provisions
guaranteeing equal rights for example
they are just creating quote new
modalities for racism
so then we go over to
dismantlingracism.org which says
here's what it says racism is ordinary
the normal way that society does
business the common everyday experience
of most people of color in this country
racism serves the interests of both
white people in power
the elites materially and working class
white people physically
and therefore neither group has much
incentive to fight it
later on it says white supremacy is ever
present in our institutional and
cultural assumptions that assign
values morality goodness and humanity to
the white group while casting people of
communities of colors
and communities of color as worthless um
immoral bad and inhuman and undeserving
and then it defines racism as racism
equals
race prejudice and social and
institutional power
racism equals a white supremacy system
all right so what does all this mean it
means that
everything is racist again racism is
everywhere
america is a white supremacist country
but also importantly
racism is a uniquely white phenomenon
only white people can be racist racism
equals a white supremacy system
now there are a few problems here of
course uh
first of all you know this this
obviously is nonsensical
it doesn't even take into account the
existence of the whole rest of the world
even if i agreed that in this country
black people can't be racist because
whites
against whites because whites have all
the power which i most emphatically
do not agree with that but even if i did
what about
say china or india there's a lot of
racism in india
racism between and towards non-white
people racism directed from one
non-white group
to another non-white group what about um
for example a person in india who hates
black africans
and that is not an unheard of phenomenon
i can tell you to put it mildly by this
definition of racism
that's not racist this definition of
racism has no way to account for that
so you see here this weird dynamic where
critical race theorists while hating
white people also in a strange way
put white people on a pedestal or at
least at the center stage of the world
play
um when talking about things like racism
or slavery for that matter
they pretend that nobody else exists and
that everything revolves around white
people
and so somehow white people are
responsible for things that have existed
in human civilization literally since
its inception
feminists do a very similar thing with
men by the way hating men
um but yet also centering their whole
lives and world views around men
so this is a common theme on the left
but okay
going along with the crt camp and
pretending for a moment
that india doesn't exist and china
doesn't exist two countries that are
rife with racism
but pretending they don't exist what
about here
is it true that in this country only
whites can be racist because whites have
all the institutional power
no that's a false conclusion built on a
false premise
and it's so faulty and so stupid that
even if the false premise was true
the conclusion still would be false
because it doesn't follow from it
it's not true that whites have all the
institutional power that is
observationally false you can look
around for yourself and see
that not all institutions are run by
white people nor are all institutions
dedicated to the advancement of white
people there are a lot more white people
in positions of power than black yes in
terms of raw numbers
but that's because there are a lot more
white people period
black people are 13 of the population a
minority of the population is also going
to be a minority of most
institutions at all levels that's just a
mathematical inevitability
but even so whites don't have all the
institutional power
we did have a black president after all
and though the left scoffs at that
response to the america's racist charge
scoffing is not an argument it is an
absence of an argument
you can laugh and roll your eyes all you
want the fact is that you cannot say
black people don't have institutional
power
when the most powerful man in the
country for the eight of the last 12
years was a black man
that claim makes no sense it is
incoherent
what about laws are laws constructed to
advance white people
no in fact the opposite
there are no laws no laws period at all
that explicitly favor white people no
laws
in this country at all there are laws
that explicitly
disfavor white people affirmative action
and related policies
okay you cannot provide an example of an
affirmative action type
thing that explicitly favors whites
because it doesn't exist
it does exist on the reverse so all of
that is wrong
but the fact that that facts don't
support critical race theory and
actually contradicted every step of the
way is irrelevant of course
crt is a religious system it is a dogma
when you read a supposedly scholarly
explanation of crt what you're really
reading is a catechism
the idea that racism lies at the root of
all things invisible and undetected
and that racism itself is some sort of
strange and mysterious way
in some sort of strange mysterious way
is a white invention or or a tool
wielded by western white civilization
even though
even though racism existed in humanity
before western white civilization even
existed itself
and certainly before it had power like
it does today these ideas cannot be
factually proven or supported
and that's by design they are statements
of faith not fact
and those who teach crt or rather
proselytize it are not looking to
convince you on an intellectual level
they're looking for your spiritual and
emotional ascent
and if they can't have that then your
cow submission
will have to do and that is why trump
you know i think should expand his war
against this poisonous religious
ideology beyond federal contractors and
into schools
where it really starts and where it's
the most dangerous
it should be banned from public schools
it should be banned on the basis that it
infringes on the first amendment
if teachers cannot get up in front of
the class and insist that their students
accept jesus christ as their lord and
savior
that they shouldn't be able to get up
and insist that you know their students
accept critical race theory dogmas
either
these are both religious doctrines the
fact that in my view one is true and one
is not is irrelevant
i don't want public schools demanding
fealty
to religious dogmas even christian
dogmas
so i think it should be banned from
public schools ban it from public
universities
impose financial penalties on any public
education
institution that promotes it personally
i think teachers who use their power and
influence to brainwash children into
this horrid
superstition deserve to go to jail but
fines and defunding would suffice for
now i guess
if people want to you know go out on
their own and explore critical race
theory
and pledge their devotion to its tenants
they're free to do that
but our public institutions should not
be in the business of promoting it
which by the way the fact that our
public institutions
do promote critical race theory is
ironically
proof in itself that critical race
theory is false
but i don't expect its proponents to
connect those dots because one thing
we've learned about critical race theory
is that
it certainly doesn't involve any
critical thinking
hey you uh yeah you you're right you
right there
hit the subscribe button right now do it
do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it's
somewhat appreciated